to ask how are you how are you doing at
the moment
uh well badly um i describe every day as
bad
um some days are
really awful and some are absolutely
terrible there's no point in hiding it
um it is absolutely shocking shocking
the impact of suicide it's estimated 135
people are affected by every suicide
and that's not just family and close
friends
but in my case having known someone for
45 years have been married to them for
40 years
and having this come completely out of
the blue
with no warning at all and being
completely unprepared for it
the impact is absolutely shattering will
continue to be so for the rest of my
life
tell us then just a little bit about
about roads and the 45 years that you
spent together
just losing someone losing anyone that
you have known for that amount of time
would be painful enough but to lose your
companion
must have been the hardest thing
yeah well you're quite right companion
is very good i mean she was we've known
each other since we were at cambridge
where we were in history
she was easily my best friend we were
married we were very young at 23
um and she was obviously i would say so
a very very wonderful person
she's extremely intelligent she's
extremely well read she had extremely
good judgment in
in books art and horses
she's great horse women she's immensely
popular
and going to entry last weekend where
she was chairman we were just touched by
everybody from all the catering staff
the groundsman right up to the
chairmanship executive all
extraordinarily kind about her
she did a lot of charity work she hated
fundraising actually um but
she was very very good uh with people
right across
the board and she was obviously
political she helped me a lot in my
political career
and what was so sad was her her own
career was really blossoming
you know she'd been very successful
chairman of the entries she made it
a very different place she made it much
more welcoming to non racing people she
had
really taken on the metropolitan press
who had this sort of tedious narrative
on ladies day trying to find unhelpful
photographs of locals enjoying
themselves
she said be fair she launched this great
fashion show she launched the grand
women's summit
which celebrated uh women's success in
sports right across all sports
um and then she was working with the
jockey club on horse welfare because
uh she was very knowledgeable about
horses she had a real feel for horses
actually done things to make entry an
absolute world leader in safety and
and welfare the washtown area in entry
is literally unique
uh where horses have cooled down after
racing and she brought her in direct
experience
uh from eventing where she'd help my
daughters uh hammer to career
and my daughter's in the british team
for three times and she learns a lot and
it's just it's just so so tragic this
has all been thrown away
in our view completely unnecessarily and
our
our view is that no suicide's inevitable
absolutely no suicide is necessary uh
i think rose's probably victim to sort
of impulse we we know she was anxious i
always make this distinction me anxious
and depressed
i had a caricature idea before i began
to learn a bit more about suicide and
i'd like to thank everybody who's been
advising me the last few months
rose didn't show the classic signs of
depression she wasn't on any medication
she wasn't obviously miserable she
wasn't living alone she hadn't turned to
drugs or alcohol
but she was anxious and and our message
is uh
please talk it goes both ways and those
around people who might be anxious
should be looking out for it
and shouldn't be holding back and being
embarrassed they should they should
approach people and i would say that now
at work today if you see someone don't
stomp on straight onto the
to the coffee machine have a word you
just might do some good
and if we'd been more aware of the
symptoms
we might have taken action things might
be very different and of course it cuts
the other way if people
who are anxious were less restrained and
less buttoned up
and less worried about taboo of
admitting it
uh if if rosa mentioned this once to us
everything would have been
very very different so our message
is very much to everybody please be much
more aware of it and please talk
i would like to see far more extensive
suicide awareness training
because this is a huge issue six six and
a half thousand people
kill themselves every year that's 15
jumbo jets
in the next 90 minutes one person
will take their life and that impacts
i've said 135 people that's nearly a
million people
dramatically impacted by suicide
and we know that the the impact of the
economic downturn in 2008 didn't really
come through in suicide
2012 so i think there needs to be a
really concerted effort on this and i'd
like to see
everybody right across the health
service the nhs and education
in sport in business in trades unions in
voluntary sectors and very much in
journalism
i would like to see them all go on a
short
suicide awareness course and become much
more aware of it where you see it's been
deployed look at what joe rafferty's
done with the merseyside trust
in liverpool prison there has been a
very very significant reduction in
suicide but by deploying these very
simple techniques
and that is what we like to put up
because we've we set up the rose pants
and trust me we're raising money for
suicide prevention but
i'll see them two things that is to have
a platform on which to get this message
across
please talk please notice people are
anxious
and please be aware and if you are
feeling actually or feeling unhappy
don't bottle it up please please talk
because they are they are obviously by
far the biggest victim of this horror
and those who tragically take their own
lives
i mean that that that that is almost the
thing isn't to mr patterson we have made
such great strides
forward in in mental health provision in
terms of
the ability of people to talk about it
and yet it still
seems a very difficult conversation for
some people to have and
and not just with people that they don't
know but with the people that they are
they're
they're nearest and dearest to the
people that they are closest to
so how best to kind of get over that
hurdle
in your mind
that's the key question absolutely key
if you're embarrassed to talk to your
own family talk to a friend at work
go and see your doctor bring up the
samaritans bring up mine but don't be
embarrassed about it
the shattering consequences are so huge
of going to the next step and so utterly
terrible first of all for yourself
if you're feeling anxious but for those
around you
just please take this first step and and
it would just make such a difference in
so many cases i i we are absolutely
convinced
if rose had mentioned this to any of us
um things would have been very very
different
we we knew she was anxious all sorts of
things anxious about things in my
political life
uh she thought she she just liked the
sort of press story she was very
sensitive it got more sense of the press
as her life went on
but we had no idea absolutely no idea
that
the extent went as far as taking this
very dramatic step of course it sounds
idiotic
simple things say this is permanent
there is no going back
and i think some of these suicides
happen on an impulse a very good
expression i had from
um someone i know very well who uh who
very very nearly took his own life was
it's like a snake bite
you suddenly have this surge and you're
blinded and you think everything will be
resolved everyone be better off without
you
or it's another good expression it's
like a mental heart attack
and so this can happen very very quickly
and if someone's very determined and
very competent like like rose was
the consequences are absolutely
catastrophic because they follow it
through
so i'm very very aware that we we need
to be talking about this much more
that's why i'm being absolutely brutally
frank doing these incidents
because i i really hope someone out
there just might be listening and think
oh well perhaps
i know it's difficult but perhaps i will
talk to my daughter about this and it
will be a bit embarrassing to start with
but the the consequences are
unbelievably appalling the anguish we
are suffering
is barely tolerable well i mean we've
got liberty
i i'm so sorry for for stumbling into
your words there but we we we have to
leave it there mr patterson i really
hope that people have
have taken your candor to heart uh this
morning very very briefly if people want
to assist
at the rose patterson trust how can they
help
uh let's google up the rose patterson
trust uh we've got just giving we've got
text giving
um we'd be grateful for any help at all
and our intention is to help
uh smaller charities and projects
there's wonderful work being done by the
big boys like samaritan's mind
but i think through the lockdown it's
been very difficult for the smaller
charities we think there's a lot of good
work to be done on the ground
we're possibly looking in rural areas my
family are very keen on
addressing suicide and women although
according to suicides
are women uh we we know there's an
increase in mental distress about
younger women this is possibly driven by
uh social media and
there are a number of areas we think we
can actually really do some good
and our our aim is very simple if we can
help just one family just help one
single family
from avoiding the horror that we're
going through we will have done a little
bit of good and that's our very simple
aim
on paterson um thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us this
morning and we wish you all the very
best of luck uh with the trust in memory
of your
wife uh on paterson thanks for being
with us very much
thank you if you've been affected by any
of the issues that we've just been
discussing the number for the samaritans
at the bottom of your screen 116 123
or you can instead email joejo
samaritans.org